un chiffre à faire pâlir d'envié
certains voisins avec 2 % de sa
population ayant reçu une injection
contre le coc vite 19 le danemark fait
figure de bon élève dans l'union
européenne
les danois ont laissé le scepticisme de
côté la demande pour se faire vacciner
explose comme ici dans la province de
zélande
le problème majeur auquel nous sommes
confrontés en ce moment c'est la demande
de la population
ils sont très impatients de se faire
vacciner et nous aimerions beaucoup
satisfaire leurs deux mondes
mais ce n'est pas possible nous recevons
de si petite quantité selon le dernier
bilan publié ce jeudi près de 130 mille
danois ont reçu une dose du vaccin files
heures biotech comme prévu dans la
stratégie vaccinale le personnel de
santé les personnes les plus vulnérables
sont prioritaires pour faire face à
l'afflux de patients des médecins
retraités ont été appelés en renfort
je vais rester sur le pont jusqu'à ce
qu'on finisse le travail et après je
retourne à ma retraite
le gouvernement danois espère vacciner
toutes les personnes volontaires d'ici
le mois de juin soit 80% des danois
d'après les sondages ce vendredi une
dose du vaccin moderna a été injectée
pour la première fois au danemark le
pays dispose pour le moment de cinq
mille doses du remède du laboratoire
américain
parallèlement à la vaccination de la
population les autorités danoises
s'inquiète de la propagation du braille
anglais sur leur territoire 208 cas ont
été officiellement recensés selon le
dernier pointage réalisé mercredi
conséquence les autorités prolongent les
restrictions en vigueur jusqu'au 7
février prochain le groupe de travail y
compris les autorités sanitaires
estiment que la propagation de ce
variant du virus présentant risques
importants d'aggraver de façon
significative la transmission du virus
au danemark dans les semaines et les
mois à venir
tout comme d'autres mutations similaires
peuvent potentiellement se propager au
danemark
pour ces raisons le niveau de risque est
maintenu au niveau 5 valable pour tout
le pays confronté à une deuxième vague
plus violente que la première au
printemps dernier le danemark est l'un
des pays au royaume uni à avoir détecté
le plus d'infections aux variants
britannique des tests pcr permettant de
détecter ce variant
vont être déployés cette semaine dans le
pays scandinave